more than two dozen reported tornadoes
ripped through the Midwest the strong
winds tore roofs off homes and scattered
debris at least two people were hurt
more severe weather is headed for the
region today powerful thunderstorms are
expected to bring large hail and
possibly more tornadoes Adriana Diaz is
in Prairie berga Iowa where people are
cleaning up this morning Adriana good
morning good morning to give you a sense
of how powerful these winds works you
see those silos teetering about a
hundred yards back well one of them was
whipped all the way down here and is
this big pile of mangled metal the
tornado made its way across town on an
angle and the sheriff's deputy told us
if it had gone straight north residents
would have taken a direct hit severe
storms spawned tornadoes across the
Midwest Wednesday a funnel cloud crossed
this highway in Stewart Iowa another
touchdown in the city whipping up debris
an hour east in Pleasantville a tornado
shredded part of the roof on this home
tossing it across the yard and on top of
cars storms in Linn County Iowa toppled
this truck and uprooted trees Doris
Pearson saw the twister up close it
happened so quick and they always say it
makes a roar sound there was no sound it
was just upon us and that was there
emergency officials say more than 25
buildings were damaged in Pierce County
Wisconsin when a tornado moved through
at least one person was hurt deeossie on
was on her front porch with her two
young grandchildren near Farragut Iowa
when tornado sirens started wailing they
ran to their storm cellar it was like
this is a winless it was hard to keep
the voice down that's what was so scary
I thought they're gonna blow away part
of her roof is gone but she says she's
just thankful everyone's okay never been
so scared and life is good Mike we're
all okay all this grief
this system that brought the tornados
has passed through but we're still not
in the clear there is a tornado threat
again today for parts of Iowa northern
Missouri and northeastern Kansas Gale
Thank You Adriana